america's shrinking workforce a puzzle
for economists the us economy is
suffering from a labor shortage posing a
difficult puzzle for economists and
policy makers to solve americans are
quitting their current jobs at a record
pace the labor department showed data
that quits
uh increased to 4.3 million in august
the highest on record dating back to
december 2000 the gallup survey
discovered that 48 percent of the
working population the united states is
actually looking for a new job or
watching for opportunities the ongoing
labor shortage is the single most
significant threat to america's economic
recovery according to the u.s chamber of
commerce the nation's biggest business
lobbying group congress should drop the
multi-millionaire dollar tax and spend
proposals that would further undermine
the economy and focus on getting
americans back to work and helping
employers feel open jobs the business
group said in a statement yesterday i
saw an article kai i send it to you i
don't know if you have it with you or
not
yesterday there was this article that
mark cuban tweeted out do you have that
can you put that article up i send it to
you in a group text with me you and um
and uh mario i'll text it to you right
now as well matter of fact i'm gonna
send it to your ipad uh uh i'm sending
it to you right now if you see it
yeah the crypto story put that up there
for people to see very interesting what
mark cuban put up about crypto
very very interesting what mark cuban
put up on crypto if you can put that
story up kai
krypto is creating newfound wealth and
job freedom for many americans okay yeah
so check this out by the way uh when we
when we bought the bitcoin how much
should we buy the bitcoin originally for
fifty thousand one point five bitcoin
fifty thousand thirty two thousand
dollars and we gave it to you when we
gave it to you a week ago or two weeks
ago two weeks ago what price was when we
gave you that money cash 94 000. we gave
you 94 000 we transferred over to him so
bitcoin was 62 300 at that day when we
gave it we bought it at 32 we gave it to
him at 62. so instead of giving ricky
only 50 000 in bitcoin he got ninety
five thousand dollars in his account
last year we gave you a bitcoin and a
half yes okay bitcoin and help okay so
now watch this watch this here
watch this here watch this article here
okay whether you invested in
cryptocurrency or understand what it is
there's no denying that over the last
year it has demonstrated staying power
in bitcoin for instance as of time of
writing is valued at sixty one thousand
dollars per bitcoin skyrocketing nearly
fifty percent while some preconception
cryptocurrencies invested uh invis in
young and uh uh tech savvy individuals
possibly anti-establishment mindset the
bigger picture of kurt thomas has a
little more noise okay so here's what it
goes to this is the next sentence that's
the key for instance while crypto wealth
is undoubtedly growing that doesn't
necessarily mean any significant portion
of people are quitting their jobs as a
result 11 percent of the general
population reports either having
personally quit their jobs or knowing
someone who has as a result of their
crypto investments so mark cuban is
saying another reason why people quit is
because they made so much money in
crypto right now that they're just kind
of sitting there saying
i'm not i'm not a guy but he's saying
he's saying do the opposite this doesn't
mean you're wealthy officially it just
means one your investments did well you
should go back to your work and your job
anyways i'll pause your thoughts on the
shrinking workforce a puzzle for
economist tom i'm going to come to you
first yeah what's going on right here is
you gotta take a look at the service
economy who is streaming loudest about
labor shortage restaurants retails
stores that are opened again um
regardless whether it's a red or blue
state you can only have a hospitality
hospitality it's all there and those
were the people that were getting
assistance they were getting the checks
from the government for assistance and
they were a certain unemployment
assistance was coming from
uh their individual states and so what
it showed you when we only have you know
when when this all started we were at
very low unemployment right which means
we had a very low supply of workers you
screw with that supply even a little bit
it wreaks havoc and now
you what you see is the service economy
is looking for people i saw the dunkin
donuts and this was not a meme this was
really dunkin donuts hey please be
patient come on in you know we'll get to
you and if you don't like the service
maybe you'd like a job application their
point was we need somebody to serve you
the donut so that's number one and then
number two with the unemployment you
don't have to mess very much with your
labor bases and maybe it is a little bit
of crypto a little bit of an up market
and
i i think we don't appreciate just what
a wonderful engine the american economy
was and we have taken a little bit of
unemployment in there over
covid impact and now coming back with
assistance programs you don't have to
take much off the top of labor to create
a massive shortage and and i think the
um
a difficult puzzle for economists and
policy makers maybe you guys need to get
a little more maybe you're at home
meeting door doordash all you got to do
is walk down main street of any midsize
uh
city and take a look there are active
now like little help wanted signs and
the others are on the windows and i'm
like why is there help one inside on the
window they can all the job things
monster.com and everything they're
online but that's what i'm saying i'm
seeing you you didn't need to mess very
much with the labor base in america to
pinch a whole lot of industries that
desperately need need workers yeah i'll
echo what he says and then maybe a few
other things gallup poll i mean
sometimes when you're being polled do
you actually give a an honest answer
i always put a little margin in there
for some discrepancy with that um the
empowerment that employees have right
now it's so easy to quit a job
and they feel so empowered go on strike
someone else will hire you the
government will give you money yeah i
mean i i find it troubling to be honest
with you how powerful employees think
they are i think it's great you know if
you have it use it but whatnot but it's
just getting a little weird and a little
imbalanced another one of the factors is
baby boomers dying i mean there's a
there's a legitimacy to that more baby
boomers have died in the last two years
that we're working that's gonna skew
this a little bit and the last thing is
automation you know there's a lot of
businesses and industries that are going
deep on automation so you combine all
those things that tom said some of these
factors these numbers and the pandemic
right and we got a problem well a lot of
people look we just got a letter
yesterday
two days ago
they're giving the dirt stimulus
like we don't mean erica we don't catch
cash out on them
third stimulus oh do here to apply bro
everybody's getting these letters
they're giving away
ricky got his stimulus last week that
bitcoin that bitcoin
what i'm getting is they're not done
giving stimulus why would i go back to
work
it makes no sense to go back to work so
the the shortage on top of you know tom
obviously is very wise when it comes
down to this but i'm i'm getting a
letter for a third time for a stimulus
check
a third time and i just got it two days
ago why would i go back to work all i
got to do is pay my bills for you know
like a lot of these guys and i even
asked people how did you do it they gave
me the stimulus i paid my rent for six
months i kept a little money and i'm
surviving off of that
oh and then they're not paying the rent
by the way some of them are not paying
their rent yeah because now you can so
they're key they're they're sitting on
this money the majority of them
that is gonna let them get through for
the next you know eight to ten months
stimulus is like covet boosters we're
gonna have the third the fourth the
fifth it's not gonna stop i found
another mary's out there i think you
make a really good point ricky because
net one year who's freaking out right
now on terms of political strategy
democrats are freaking out there's a
whole thing going on there so if we
think these stimulus checks are going to
stop as long as they control the three
houses you know the three branches um
i i think we're missing something i
think we're going to stimulus all the
way through the midterms because it's
going to be like it's going to be like
candy to the voters
i don't know tom i have a very i at this
table i have a very minority opinion on
this i know already stimulus is nothing
new 40 acres and a mule is nothing new
manifest destiny is nothing new there's
always been an incentive the government
pays people to go do whatever it wants
to do right so if they want to stimulate
not the way it's happening right now
sure understood but nothing's happening
the way that's ever happened before
technology is different this is actually
it's a great point that's what i'm
saying just remember 40 of the money
that's ever been printed in the united
states as pat is pointing out several
times what happened in the last 20
months i understood completely but
here's the thing big stack training you
are where you you brought up uh you
brought up dunkin donuts before right if
i'm working at dunkin donuts and it's
12.75
an hour all right and i'm looking at a
iced coffee being sold for 550 i'm
saying to myself an hour of my life is
only worth two freaking iced coffees no
it's the gig more than crypto which by
the way one of the first podcasts i did
crypto was tanking you were kind of
making fun of me for crypto you're like
you're the cell i was like absolutely
not i buy the dip and then like right so
i mean i'm all remember that but okay
i'm sure our guys pbd podcast instagram
can find it the uh but there's
crypto is the future especially when we
get into the middle of metaverse crypto
is the president it's not even the
future and it's more than cryptos the
gig economy where the young generation
is not getting married they're not
having kids they're not buying houses
right you talked about rent half these
guys it's okay like remember back on in
the day chris farley had that great uh
that great segment if you don't do this
you'll be smoking the reefer or living
in a van
van lifestyle is a whole thing people
they get these vans and they deck them
out and it's called mini living and they
do this thing the young generation
understands that their time is worth
something to them and it's not 12.75
what the businesses especially these
massive large chains have not figured
out is how to attract that employee and
i think yeah
the solution i don't think it's the
money i honestly think it's the hours i
think that the first person that goes
i'm going to pay your rent and you're
only going to have to work four hours a
week for those people that don't want to
be massive millionaires then the
business is not sustainable i think this
is the only route on what the
those companies are going to be doing
here's exactly what those companies are
going to be doing they're going to stop
trying to get those young guys to work
for them they're going to automate every
single thing and they're going to say no
problem you don't want to work for 1250
which is the minimum wage it's not
really that it doesn't take that much to
flip a burger but you don't want to be a
barista for 15 bucks an hour totally
fine we'll automate all of this
eventually it'll be automated
short term
short term the employers win long term
the employees win short term the
employer wins long term sure because the
employers also if any time you're
looking for a solution here's how this
works you can sit there and say
well you know uh do it screw it i'm just
gonna go out there and do this you're
right every time i've done that as a
human being i made a short term decision
and it was successful
for a month three months six months 12
months long term it was not successful
correct these decisions what you're
talking about could be short-term
success it's going to be catastrophic
long-term because math the math doesn't
make sense so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you